on va maintenant demander à serge
khalfon de bcr
bouge pas tant maintenant on va
recommencer n'allant va le refaire
on rallume non j'en ai vu qu ont bougé
est-ce qu'on peut rallumer eu voilà
l'attention pendant les hymnes on ne
bouge pas non attention un coût 3
mon premier souvenir
un souvenir avec mon grand père je dois
avoir 3 ans et demi et je suis cachée
sous une table ronde où il ya un prompt
et je pique du saucisson c'est rigolo
petit chamonix c'est rigolo on est le
père de jane votre premier choc dans la
vie votre premier choc brutal mais
revers
je dirais sûrement la mort de mon grand
père qui est intervenu très peu de temps
un ca a été cet élément a placé sur la
loire de mon grand père c'est à une
journal différence c'est sa première
balle mes parents ne m'ont jamais ni pas
fichés juste maintenir qui m'a mis à
vraiment la gueule car on perd mais
c'était en fait on joue à mike tyson sur
l'île et je lui en ai décroché le
câliner besoin d elle à regarder par
terre et j'ai senti que ça n'allait pas
trop bien et je suis dit pardon apprenez
s'est retournée chez moi c'est ça a
passé les douanes yayoro jamais le gard
pardon pas boudé la réunion du dans
votre premier objet fétiche dressage non
non un four ma maman à la flore et
saint-jean pioche est évidemment quand
je suis né m'a donné un singe et moi
j'adore ça louvière h éveil quand
j'étais tout petit et je les appelais
nacarat et serait un singe pour le
premier le péché je crois que c'est
quand j'ai dû voir un jour j'ai piqué
sont mal à ma mère quand j'étais tout
petit pour aller acheter plein de
moments avec mes copines je croise
toutes premières comme les prières dans
les rues
ouais moi j'ai faites vous aussi la cité
n'a jamais été une maman votre nom
nouveau premier amour la nasa va c'est
le fisc la meilleure des mamans qui
s'appelait harry dont je connais mais
amoureuse pour tout petit à 6 ans ont
été entendus sur la plage et il m'a dit
d'ailleurs à sion à ce que je trouve
assez votre fils faisait du chantage
toute la journée où je me cachais avec
lui et si moment à ces pages où je
hurlais meta hurler plus personne faut
une quinzaine de membres à ce votre
première cuite avant et demie 14 ans 13
ans et plus
j'habitais dans les caraïbes quand j'ai
13 ans et 13 ans donc kamikazes est ce
que c'est je me rappelle plus ce que
c'est ça c'est la face à ces la
tradition gainsbourg les cocktails le
kamikaze de votre 1er juin
la même époque quand ils ont une
déviance voyage assez chouette cela est
votre premier extrait ça c'est chouette
ça dépend de la hat ans dirigera je
crois que j'en ai jamais pris sauf
peut-être une fois on a filé dans un
verre parce que je crois que j'étais
plus excité que j'aurais que j'aurais
été en buvant un verre quand je courais
un peu ample et sont donc là j'écris je
crois que le mec à qui vous pensez vous
avez pris à l'extase à votre insu d'
mais parce qu'on a mis dans mon arrêt je
sais pas mais c'est juste que j'ai couru
dans tous les sens plus insisté les deux
étapes du tour de france c'était la
première fois la preuve l'interview
première fois et tout le monde vous a
trouvé formidable
merci